[Applause]
very very nice
that's gonna feel good that feels great
you guys make me feel so good
it looks like a giant body loofah
your whole body was just luffed with
love that was fantastic that was a nice
alliteration it was disgusting uh
you know it's funny you came out here
with all this energy and because of you
we no longer have a glass
table here because you were on this show
once and you uh you were great you were
really energetic you ended up smashing
our glass coffee table i think we have a
quick clip of that
i don't remember
so i don't remember why andy was wearing
that wig
the idea was because i i played a
character called hesher and that would
be called hesher and we were going to
head bang so you got my head bang you
put on heavy metal music what do you
think i'm going to do i know and so
anyway because of you we now have the
joseph gordon-levitt rule which is they
replaced it our set guys replaced this
with an indestructible
polyurethane you changed your set for me
for you we now have something you can't
break that if you andy
you're just teasing him i'm not i'm not
it's good to have you here don't don't
smash it don't try to smash you'll hurt
yourself but it won't break if i did
i don't i'm told you can't break no now
what are we doing
you can try i don't think you're gonna
break you can't break it you just can't
break it it's feel that and knock on
that that's made of no
[Applause]
you almost lost your legs
you know uh i thought you were fantastic
in the movie lincoln thank you and it
was one of my favorite movies of the
year i'm such a history buff and lincoln
fan and i was just how intense i've
heard all these rumors about daniel
day-lewis that he became lincoln on the
set for the entire shoot of the movie
that he stayed in character is that true
and if so how did you work with that guy
it's kind of true i mean he's not
ridiculous about it he knows that you
know we shot it in what i guess it was
2011. he knows it's not actually
does that be annoying if he was
constantly like what is this device
you know that would get old really fast
that would be annoying for a few reasons
yeah
i don't know if this is true but i heard
a rumor that he really took the death
scene of lincoln very seriously
obviously it's a serious moment but that
as an actor he really approached that i
felt really lucky to be there that was
actually that was the last day of
shooting was uh the day that we shot him
on his deathbed sorry to spoil the movie
but it ends with uh lincoln's
there's three people in the audience
going no
no spoilers no but he he stayed in the
bed all day long even in between takes
when they were changing the camera
around he just i never saw him move he
stayed in bed wow the whole time and
then the crazy thing was that at the end
steven spielberg directed it came came
in and said okay
we're done
and for the first time i i saw him get
up and and begin to shed
this character and uh hear his you know
irish accent that he's born with uh uh
began to creep back into his voice kind
of right away and then until that night
we all you know had a celebration and
dinner and drinks and he was so excited
to drink beer because he hadn't had a
beer or anything for a year lincoln
didn't drink so he did i mean he takes
it that far he takes it extremely far
which i love because if you're gonna do
something you know yes get into it and
clearly what he's doing is working it
would be really funny to me if an actor
did all that and was terrible
[Laughter]
they were just awful yeah and their
movies were awful but they were like now
i'm gonna become the character of stinky
you know and they were just
and they stink